be alone it's okay to be alone
people get freaked out when they're
alone it's okay to be alone it's okay
it's okay to be alone there's no big
deal enjoy it
do something productive
and build that trust up in yourself you
know look back at the situation learn
from it start with yourself right rely
on yourself trust yourself because we
when when someone breaks our trust we we
we question ourselves too yes like we
think our my judgment's bad I'm not a
good judge of human character because I
totally put my faith in this person look
what they did to me so now we don't
trust her so you gotta build that trust
up you got to build that trust up back
again with yourself how do you do that
read write learn work out and then look
for them next time around because you
deal with people all the time that they
they made mistakes the first run
they go back they make the same mistakes
the second run they go back and make the
same mistakes the Third Run that's when
you gotta start blaming yourself yeah on
your situation
that's why that's why I said you got to
like build a relationship with yourself
you gotta learn yourself you gotta trust
you got to learn to trust yourself
so spend some time doing that
there's a process to all this stuff man
the process starts with you gotta shut
off technology yeah go here
I call it the dark room where you're
alone no cell phones no music no TVs no
computers you buy yourself very few
people want to be alone anymore they
want to be around no ways and you can't
think be alone go that dark space in
that dark space shut life off for a
little bit go to a dark place in your
mind and figure out what you want to be
you don't know what you don't want
because you don't know what you want to
be
because you haven't spent time Real Time
with yourself
spend time with yourself
trust me and once you find that passion
that purpose
your goals your purpose everything when
they start lining up when I was growing
up there was this statement I think it
was Pascal he said you know all of man's
problems arise because he cannot sit by
himself in a room for 30 minutes alone
and it's very true I've always needed to
be stimulated and when the iPhone came
along boredom was dead I would never be
bored again even if I'm standing in line
I'm on my iPhone and I thought it was
great and when I was a kid I used to try
and overclock my brain be like how many
thoughts can I think at once the answer
is only one but I would try to like
think multiple thoughts at once and I
was proud of that I was proud that my
brain was always running this engine was
always moving and it's a disease it's
actually the road to misery and now that
I'm older I realize like you actually
want to again rest your mind you want to
learn how to settle into your mind now I
look forward to solitary confinement you
leave me alone for a day it'll be like
the happiest day I've had in a while
and and that is a superpower that I
think everybody can attain
the superpower of learning to be alone
and enjoying it yeah I know people who
lives have been ruined because somebody
wasn't good for them see there are some
people that aren't good for you hello
they aren't good for you you've got to
get them out of your life see a lot of
people put up with a lot of foolishness
because they don't want to die by
themselves here's what I believe I
believe in a one to a box Theory ask
this question of yourself make a list of
who you communicate with most and ask
yourself the question what kind of
person am I becoming because of this
relationship
is it helping me to grow mental and
emotionally and spiritually am I
becoming a better person because of this
relationship do they bring out the best
in me do they inspire me
do they encouraged me to develop my
greatness do they make me stretch
see you got to look at the people in
your life and find out what kind of
person are you becoming because of that
relationship my mother used to say birds
of a feather flock together you run
around with losers you will end up a
loser
straight up move
forget them
they are lying
and they are untrustworthy so move on
now sometimes this can be hard
especially if they've somehow tied
themselves into your life especially
like for instance
kids involved in a divorce scenario you
you can't move on
but you have to mentally move on you
have to emotionally detach from that
human and that's hard to do
because obviously they were someone that
you trusted
be and the reason I know that you
trusted them is because they got to a
point where they were able to betray
your trust and destroy you so it's hard
but the fact that they trust that you
trusted them the fact that you had that
relationship
that's even more reason to walk away
it's even more reason to move on you
gotta see them
for what they are
that person is not who you thought they
were the idea
that this person
was a trustworthy faithful companion is
not true
it is not true that person does not
exist
they didn't exist and they don't exist
it was in your head it was in your head
that this person was trustworthy and you
the they were everything you wanted them
to be and they were faithful commanded
that is a lie they are not that person
they've proved it by their actions
so move on and at the risk of sounding
callous get over it do not dwell on do
not dwell on on what it was
and don't dwell on what it could have
been you you're when guys go through bad
breakups
don't dwell on that deal with what it is
right now what that person is deal with
reality accept reality and be be
thankful for reality be thankful that
you were able to learn before you
invested more into this person be
thankful that you found out when you did
that this person was a liar that this
person was unfaithful is untrustworthy
be be thankful that you know it and you
know it now instead of later and you
know what else is going to make it a lot
easier to get over these situations is
recognize that there's plenty of people
out there in the world that are
trustworthy and that are faithful good
people they're out there
go find one of them but don't think that
that person that you had was the only
one in the world they're not
it's great when people believe in US
cheer us on make us feel valuable we
love when our spouse compliments us a
friend is there to give encouragement
our co-worker stays late to help us on
the project God uses people to help move
us toward our destiny but here's the key
you can't become so dependent on people
that you're getting your worth and value
out of how they treat you
it's easy to become addicted to
compliments addicted to encouragement
addicted to them cheering you on now you
rely on them to keep you feeling good
about yourself to always be there to
validate you to make you feel approved
like a drug if they don't keep you fixed
meet all your expectations you get
discouraged feel inferior work overtime
to try to win their approval the problem
is you're trying to get from people what
only God can give your worth your value
doesn't come from another person it
comes from your creator if you rely on
people you'll be disappointed people
will let you down
people will get busy and not be there
when you need it sometimes people will
even turn on you some of you you are
taking too much time trying to convince
people to love you that do not matter
some of you are taking way too much time
tolerating and trying to get people
engaged that don't matter that don't
care that are never ever going to help
you get into your destiny
sand you this week if somebody can walk
away from your life let them walk away
you shouldn't have to convince anybody
to love you if they can walk let them go
if they leave you it means they're not
attached to your future
we spend so much time wasting energy
because we're so upset about being
rejected by people what if I told you
that some of the rejection you have been
facing in your life it's because people
are jealous of what's on your life what
if I told you that the rejection is
simply an indication that you got favor
on your life God is getting ready to do
something in your life you just got to
understand there's more to know we live
in an external world
everything is is you got to see it touch
it it's external
if you can for
the rest of your life live inside of
yourself
listen to people who are calling you fat
gay transect everything that is makes no
sense all these insecure people putting
their insecurities on you you gotta
flush it out
you gotta just be whoever the hell God
or whoever the hell you believe in if
you believe in nothing but yourself I
don't care what it is you got to take
everything and throw it away
you have to believe in one thing and
that is yourself
and and I'm not saying don't believe in
God or what you believe in but right now
for you to find greatness in yourself
you're not going to find it by looking
in a book or by even hearing me I may
give you the spark but you've got to go
inside yourself to find it and that
means you gotta be quiet shut the go in
a room stop talking search your soul
search your mind search your abilities
and you'll find it
but if you're not looking for it you
won't find it so you got to go start
your journey and the journey starts with
you finding why the hell am I here on
this planet Earth
why am I here if you don't know that you
will live the rest of your life
searching always asking the question why
[Music]